While Republican Senator Ted Cruz was flying
back and forth from Cancun, Mexico, late two
weeks ago, Democratic New York Congresswoman
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez was raising millions
of dollars for Ted Cruz's Texas constituents
and was volunteering at the Houston Food Bank
for Ted Cruz's constituents.
Now, Ted Cruz, thank AOC.
No, he didn't.
Did Texas Gov..
Greg Abbott thank AOC and Better O'Rourke
and all the other Democrats who fundraised
for Texans?
They didn't, did they?
Thank AOC and other Democrats who flew to
Texas and went to work at the Houston Food
Bank to help Ted Cruz's constituents know
they didn't thank them for that either, either.
And when Ted Cruz finally mentioned AOC, it
was Friday during his CPAC speech.
We saw this clip earlier during our Ted Cruz
clip.
Here it is again.
Here is Ted Cruz making fun of AOC for her
experience during the January 6th Trump riots.
Bernie.
Is wearing mittens.
And AOC is telling us she was murdered.
And the media desperately, desperately, desperately
wants to see a Republican civil war.
Now, what is Ted Cruz even talking about,
aside from just being a disgusting human being?
Ted Cruz is referring to the Twitter exchange
in which AOC had tweeted that, quote, There
must or not not quote, which she tweeted that
there must be an investigation of Robin Hood
for their role in the GameStop fiasco.
And Ted Cruz retweeted AOC saying, I fully
agree.
And AOC, instead of sort of accepting Ted
Cruz's, I guess, bipartisanship, AOC tweeted
a rebuke of Ted Cruz saying, quote, I'm happy
to work with Republicans on this issue where
there is common ground.
But you almost had me murdered three weeks
ago.
So you can sit this one out.
Happy to work with almost any other Republicans
that aren't trying to get me killed.
In the meantime, if you want to help, you
can resign.
Now, some people loved this response from
AOK, saying it's AOC standing by her principles,
regardless of whether on this one issue, Ted
Cruz agrees with her.
Others were sort of upset that AOK responded
aggressively to a senator saying, I want to
do I agree with you on this particular issue.
Now, Ted Cruz is so disgusting that I do tend
to side with ABC on this particular one.
But this is less about AOC and more about
the fact that even Republicans from Texas,
who did nothing for their constituents during
the storm, can't simply thank AOC for what
she did do for Texas.
AOC has done more for Texans than their own
senator.
Dozens of people died in Texas.
AOK helped them, raised money, went to Texas,
went to a Houston food bank and worked.
Ted Cruz went to Cancun and he's making fun
of the the you know, everybody lighten up
is the type of thing people say when they
failed to deal with something serious and
they want everybody else to take it less seriously.
That's how they tell everyone not to worry
about it.
Now, maybe people like Ted Cruz, C.A.C., as
a sucker for helping Texans.
What I mean is she didn't have to do it.
Like, legally speaking, Texans aren't her
constituents.
She's the sucker.
Maybe that's the view Ted Cruz has.
AOC was suckered into helping people who don't
even get to vote for her one way or the other.
Either way, these are really pathetic people
and we can only hope that they are eventually
held accountable.
And like I said last week, unfortunately,
with Ted Cruz's next election, if he chooses
to run for reelection still four years away,
I'm not super optimistic that this entire
fiasco is really going to hit him in any way
that it will actually hurt.
I hope to be wrong.
But I mean, you know, when a Democratic New
York congresswoman is doing more for Texas
constituents than their own senator who's
trying to escape to the beach in Mexico, you
know that one of two things is going on.
No.
One, either.
Voters really don't care what their elected
officials do, and they care only about what
they say, which is quite probable.
Or two, there may not we may just not have
a system that has consequences for bad actors
in the political system, in which case we
have to figure out other ways to win these
elections.
Probably some combination
of
the two.